ich glaube für journalisten ist es
wichtig dazu seine geschichte
geschrieben wird und manchmal wenn
geschichte geschrieben wird ist es
gefährlich das ist unser berufsrisiko
kriegs und krisenberichterstattung
müssen ein risiko auf sich nehmen um das
zu zeigen was passieren
afghanistan am scheideweg die
internationalen truppen haben das land
verlassen die taliban brennen eine
region nach der anderen
tausende fürchten um ihr leben
mittendrin bild vize paul ronzheimer als
einer der wenigen westlichen
journalisten ist er vor ort ich stehe
auf einer der position der taliban diese
haben sie vor wenigen wochen ebenfalls
von der afghanischen armee zurückerobert
und die männer hinter uns mit denen ich
gesprochen habe die sagen am ende werden
sie auch kabul erobern und dort vor
allem das sagen sie ist ihnen wichtig
ihr recht ihr radikal islamische recht
umsetzen wenn das verbrechen größer ist
dann muss er gesteinigt werden oder bis
zum tod
[Musik]
wir sind stark bewaffnet wir kämpfen
gegen die taliban und verteidigen unser
land schulter an schulter
was ich finde es dass man doch merkt
dass die regierung ein bisschen fernab
der realität ist wie fern der realität
zeigt sich am 15 august die taliban
nähmen kabul praktisch kampflos ein die
hoffnung auf ein leben in freiheit sie
zerplatzt für viele nun wollen sie raus
aus dem land doch die letzte
militärmaschine der amerikaner verlässt
kabul am 30 august
kurz darauf kehrt paul ronzheimer zurück
nach afghanistan
ich bin auf dem landweg nach
kommen und zwar von usbekistan und
insgesamt war der weg für mich fast 36
stunden
es ist uns gelungen seit heute morgen
ist er wieder
bloß diesen taliban rausgesprungen
wie wild geworden und kam mit
handschellen an und wollte mich
festlegen
[Applaus]
da sind sie einer taliban-hochburg muss
man sagen und heute ist für die taliban
kämpfer ein besonderer tag sie wollen
ihren independence der iren freiheitstag
feiern
[Musik]
meine pieper und ein audi a4
avant von mrc der
superpole
die sinne patsche gebirge und dieser
panzer hinter mir diese alte tanks wurde
gestern nacht von den taliban vernommen
es ist schon sehr bitter hier gerade in
einem gefängnis zu sein wo bis vor
wenigen wochen tausende taliban waren
machtwechsel in afghanistan paul
ronzheimer bei den taliban jetzt
exklusiv mit bild plus
[Musik]